よろしくお願いします
今日はボディパッキヤダンマということに流行っているこの七覚支なんです
もう一度繰り返し申しますが
このボディパッキヤという言葉なんですけど
ボディというのは悟りのことで
パッキヤというのはそちらに入るというグループということで
悟りに関係ある言葉ということで
サンスクリット語でこれをパークシャと言いますが
パークシャというのは例えば政治的な言えば
何か党の会員みたいなものなんですね
ですから 例えば何か党
政治的な党があると思ったら
会員で成り立っているんですね
会員がなければ党もないんですね
そんな感じで その同じ言葉
サンスクリットだったらパークシャ
ボディパークシャと言うんです
パッキヤというのは サンスクリットの言葉は一応書いておきますけど
パークシャと言うんですね
だからパクシャというのは党であって
特定の党に入っているということなんです
ですから悟りに関係あるものということで
ですからボディパッキヤダンマというのは三十七ありますけど
それ全部揃ったところで悟りなんですね
ですから 特にこの部分では
仏教は実践する場合は
自分の実践の方法はね
どんどんどんどん成長して
前へ前へと進まなくちゃいけないんですね
で どのように我々の悟りをね
修行を悟りまで成長して導いていくかというと
このボディパッキヤという法を考えて理解して努力しなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうのはいっぺんに成長するわけじゃなくて
そのその人の性格によってバラバラで成長していくんですね
いくらバラバラで成長していったとしても
全部完全に成長していないと
悟りの方向へ心はいかないんですね
ですから 例えば精進のことを説明しましたし
努力することもね それをウィリヤであって
それは四つありますと
それなりに努力しなくちゃいけない
それは時々自分に現れちゃうんですね
怠けが出てきたら やっぱりこの場合は頑張らなくちゃいけないとかね
あるいは瞑想 少々上手に楽にできるようになったならば
よくできたんだから もうそれをさらに完成するまで頑張らなくちゃいけないとか
そういうふうに努力しなくちゃいけない
瞑想をよくできたような瞬間で
普通の人はどうしますかというと
すぐ あ 我ながらよくできているんだというふうにも思ってしまっちゃうんですね
自分を褒める 褒めて それで自己自慢するようになっちゃうんですね
心の中で それでもう終わりなんですけど
もう進めなくなっちゃうんですね
次にまた全く瞑想できなく
なく できないようになってしまっちゃうし
ですから うまくできたならば
頑張らなくちゃというふうに
これは完成しなくちゃ
うまくできたんだけど
完成したわけじゃないんですよと
完成しなくちゃいけないというふうに精進しなくちゃいけないし
そこで突然何か自分の心が汚れてしまったとかね
で いろんな雑事に追われて
いろいろ心がまた統一状態なくなったりすると
心の汚れが生まれたんだから
これ早くも綺麗にしなくちゃいけないということで努力しなくちゃいけないんですね
そのようにこの精進というものは
その場その場で自分でうまく活用しなくちゃいけないし
それから力もね 五つあると言ってるし
力も元々同じものなんですけど
で 修行の元になるものも修行の力になるものも同じカテゴリーなの
同じものなんですね サッダ
フリ サマーディ ウィリヤ
パンニャーという四つなんで
五つですけどね だから自分の瞑想をちょっと観察してみて
何が力がないかと 信か念か
どっちかとかね で あるいは統一性か
あるいは智慧か そういうものは私がこれは足らないなと思ったところ
それを成長するように努力しなくちゃいけない
そのようにこの三十七の法を悟りを完成するために
修行者が大変自分の心で自己観察しなくちゃいけないものとしてカテゴライズしているんです
今日のお話はその中でこの七覚支
で その七覚支の場合 また同じことで
また それはボッジャンガと言うんですね
これはボディパッキエ
七覚支はボッジャンガというんです
このボッジャンガっていうのはまた同じくこうやって出てくる言葉なんですね
ボディとアンガ ですからボディっていうのは悟り
アンガっていうのはまあ部分という部品ということなんですね
悟りの部品というもので
部品揃ったところで何か出来上がりますからね
ですからまあ 体にしたっても
いろいろ部分が臓器がまとめたところで体というものは出来上がっちゃうし
車っていうのはそれなりの部品が揃ったところで車ということが出来上がっちゃうし
そのようにこの部品が揃ったところで悟りというものは出来上がっちゃうんだと
ですから 結局はまあちょっと違う言葉使ってるだけで
この理由は 例えばボディパッキエの場合は三十七あるんですね
数えて数えれば三十七ですけど
三十七もあるわけじゃないんです
で この場合は七つなんですね
数える少なくなるんで
例えば四念がありまして
念は四つだよと 本当は念頭って数えると一つなんです
ですから この三十七もあるわけじゃないんです
でも いろんな項目でリストアップしているんですね
ですから この例えば念はどれぐらいあるかというと
身受心法と四つにする
力はどれぐらいありますよというと
また五つにする その五つの中にも念が入ってるんですね
サッターサティサマーディ
ヴィリヤパンニャー そこにもサティが入ってるんですね
ですから あの四つも一つに稼がなくちゃいけないし
この五つのまた一つサティ同じものなんですね
同じサティがいろんな項目の中に入ってるんです
で それなりのこの これは普通の論理的な説明ではちょっとできないです
説明が どういうことか
例えばサティを実践したいと人が
サティを中心にして サティをメインに考えて実践したいと思うと四念処なんですね
身受心法においてサティを実行しなくちゃいけない
だからそれすごい具体的なんですね
ある人が来て 私は私もサティのことを実践したいと言ったら
カヤ・チッタ・ヴェーダナー・ダンマ・アヌパッサナーという風に
身受心法の四つの方で頑張ってくださいと言わなくちゃいけない
また ある人が来て 私は瞑想はしているんだけど
なかなか何かまあうまくいってないんだと
それほどやる気もないんだと
力ないとわかっちゃうんですね
この人はものすごく力強くこれに当たってないんだと
この修行に そうするとあなたは五つの力を育てなさいというんですね
その場合はまたサティが入るんですね
それでその人も同じく信楽信法にサティ入れてるんだけど
それじゃなくて力強くサティを実践しなさいということになっちゃうんですね
だから信というのはもっともう自信があって
確信があって頑張りなさいと
中途半端ではなくてとか
それで力の この人は力が足らないというと
もうそういう風に同じ五つをですね
で またある人が瞑想をやってるんだけど
うまくいったり またうまくいかなかったり
もうやる気が現れたり
またやる気がなかったりとかね
それで あの 今ですか 通してまた同じ五つなんですね
あなたの根元はしっかりしてないんだと
やるぞということで決めてしっかりして
それ何に 何をやるぞと思ったら
やっぱりまた同じ サッダ―と信と念と精進と
えーと サマ 定と慧ですね
その五つ同じ五つなんですね
それをしっかりしなさいと
しっかり土台とする その五つを考えなさいと
それで同じ人が まあ考えちゃうと
じゃあ悟りに 悟りまで到達するためには
私はどんな風に どんなどんな項目を育てなくちゃいけないか
悟りそのものを考えて
悟りたいと 解脱したいんだと
それだったら私は何を完成すればいいかというと
この部品のことを言わなくちゃいけないと
あなたはこういうこういう部品を揃ってくださいと
で そこで悟りがあるんだと
それは部品の中にまた同じ念が入ってるんですね
だからこの三十七の中で同じ項目がいろんなところでもうダブって出てくるんですね
それをダブっているのは
まあ昔の人々は数学わからなかったからとかね
あの心理 あの 何か哲学的に物事を明確に分析することができなかったんですよとかね
それはまあ原始的な時代で
インド人の大雑把な考え方だと思う人々はいるんだけどね
だからそういう人々が数学はわからなくて
大雑把で原始的で哲学的ではないんであって
で そういうのは教えた人々はものすごい厳密に考えて
そういうことを書いてダブっていることはものすごい明確に知っていたんだから
例えば四聖諦を理解するためにどうすればいいかと
八正道を実行しなさい
八正道は八流です じゃあ 1番目は正見は何ですか？で言えば
四住滅道を理解することだと
だから普通の言葉だけ追ってみると
なんて言いますか 同じことを繰り返しているような
この あやまちになっちゃうんですね
だからこの四住 四住滅道の中でまた八正道入ってるんだから
それをまたそのまたその中にまた
そういうことではなくて
その人の立場である目的があって喋ってるんですね
それをものすごい明確に知っていたんです
知っていたんだけど まあ哲学だけ
哲学ではないんですね
仏教っていうのはいつでもこの一つのマニュアルであって
ある目的を実践するために人々にこのテキストになるものというか
マニュアルになるものですから
この修行者の実践者に
あの いつでも参考になるようにという言葉で書いてあるんであって
すごいかっこいい哲学を作ろうとかね
それを持って相手の師匠を倒そうということは全くなかったんです
仏教思想が出来上がったんだから
阿弥陀様が出来上がったんだからといって
敵がいないんです これ
誰に対して 誰の師匠を食わすためにこれ作ったかというと
そういうのはまるっきりないんで
相手がいないんです ただ
この何のために買うかと
相手っていうのは修行者なんです
真面目に仏教を実践している人なんです
その人のために書いているんであって
それを持って誰かに対して対立して倒そうという気持ちは全くないんです
それでお釈迦様は特別に仏教の論理っていうのは大変高度で
人間には理解できないほど難しいことでもありますが
私は明確に説明しているんだと
それで人々には理解できるんだ
だからといって これを持って争論するなんて
すごい このよくおしゃべり屋になるために
物事をすごい世の中に入って明確に分析して
こうだああだこうだと言って
偉そうに何かエリートになるためにとかね
あるいは他のいろんな師匠やらそういうものをね
まあ砕いて壊すために全く使ってはいけませんと
もう最低 私は仏教を知ってるんだということのためにも
仏教を知りたい 勉強しました
もう知ってるんだと そういうケチっぽいなね
目的のためにも使ってはいけませんと
それでマーマンイティジャノという言葉はそこで原文で書いてますけど
これをもって人々は私のことを知っていただきたいんだと
ということは この肩書きなんですね
あの人は仏教哲学者ですよと
あの人は論理学者ですよとか
そういうふうに人々は自分の立場を作っちゃうんで
アイデンティティをね
ですから 最低自分のアイデンティティを作るためでも仏教を使ってはいけませんと
ですから すごい明確なお釈迦様は
それはこの仏教というものは
この実践者のマニュアルとしてしか喋ってないんです
それでも単純明快な単純なマニュアルではなくて
大変なこの哲学はその中にはあるんです
で そういうことは別に関係ないこと言ってるかもしれませんだけど
仏教はこのいろいろ部派に分け分けて堕落していく過程では
いつでも相手がいて 相手を倒そうということをやっていたんですね
である宗派が輪廻転生する主体があるんだと
ブッダという主体があるんだ
それはもうずっとその主体が輪廻転生していくんだ
いきなり言ったりで そうすると他の人々は仏教ではそんな主体はあるわけじゃないんだから
それとせっかくお釈迦様おっしゃった教えはそれだけで壊れてしまいますからね
それに反対する それでも宗派が二つに分かれると
で このセセッサイウブという宗派がいて
この今アビダンマは我々とほとんど同じアビダンマを持ってるんです
セセッサイウブのアビダンマは上座仏教のアビダンマよりは古いんです
で それなのに彼らがこの法は過去現在未来において存在しているんだと
過去のものを存在しているんだと未来のものが存在しているんだという三世論と言うんですね
それが そう言うと じゃあ無常はどうしますか？ということになってしまっちゃうんですね
で それを争論しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
無常はあなた方はどうしますか？例えば地水火風あります
それはもう過去の地も将来の地も今の地の中にあるんだと言っちゃうと
無常はなくなっちゃうんですね
言ったらそちら側がまた攻撃するんです
いえ そんなことはないんだと
で 私たちには過去のことを思い出せるでしょうし
だから何か思い出すためには
頭にその情報が入らなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでなんで過去のことを思い出せるかというと
やっぱりその情報が意に
意門に触れたっていうことなんですね
だからやっぱり法があるんだと
過去という法があるんだと
意門に触れたんだから
で 亡くなった母親のことを思い出しちゃうと
ちゃんと思い出せるし
もしかしてまあ亡くなった時悲しくなったら
また後で思い出す時でも同じく悲しくなったりするし
ということは やっぱり何か良いものに触れたんだと
触れたものはそれなりに実際しないともうエネルギーになりませんだからやっぱり過去が実際するんだと
同じことで まあ若い人はこれから自分に生まれてくる子供のことを考えちゃうと
まだ結婚してもないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそれなりの感情が生まれたりするんだから
やっぱり将来の方も未来の方も実際しているんだという風に
そちらまた劣屈してくれる
で それでお互いにやっぱり宗派に分け分けなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
それからいろんなそういうふうに概念作って
概念作って で それでやがてそれを攻撃するために空論というものが出てきて
で 空論は出てきてなかったんだけど
タッニャパーリニタというハンニャという名前のタッニャという名前の経典はどんどんどんどん書き始めるんですね
で それまた嘘を言ってるし
なぜならばお釈迦様はどこかどこかでこういう風に言ったんですよ
言ってないんですけど
もう亡くなってるんだけど
ですから嘘まで言ってある哲学を作ろうとしている
ですから このこの そういう風に書いて
経典どんどん自分を攻撃する相手が相手のことを清浄仏教だというのは言ったりもする
敵がいるんですね それは決して仏教哲学でも仏教思想でも何でもない
敵がいないはずなんです
ただ真理を説明してあげるだけで
それを誰かに当たるために
攻撃するために使ってはいけないことなんですね
で なんでそういう人々はそんなことをしました
宗派に分かれたかというと
仏教は実践するためにあるんだから
実践する人にとってはそんなことをやる暇がないんです
ただ実践して自分の心を清らかにするだけで清らかになったら
その人はもう仏教の真理を知ってるんだから
しっかりと あ これは真理だよと
全然もう別れたり 誰かと喧嘩したりはしません
ですから あくまでもこの宗派に分かれたということ自体で哲学を作ったということで見えるのは
誰一人も実践してなかったということなんですね
実践することを置いておいて
頭で考えるではないか
で そこをおかしくなったところで
また空という概念が出てきて
で そういう概念 全部初期仏教には確実にあるんです
この世襲一切言っているような
この過去も現在も未来も実際するよということについても
まあそれなりの言葉をお釈迦様の言葉の中にないわけでもないんです
いわゆる時間を説明する場所がありまして
なぜ過去かというと あるものは消えたということで過去だと
なぜ将来かということは
あるものはまだ現れてないと
そういうわけで将来と言うんだと
そういう言葉からものすごく妄想して
妄想して 三世論を作っちゃうんですね
お釈迦様というのはごく一般的なことなんですね
修行に必要なことだけなんですね
で 物はもう現象がもうないならば
それはもう過去やと 今現象があるならば
それは現在だと だからこれから現れる現象は未来だと
やっぱり現象に基づいて
単なる過去・現在・未来っていうのは人間の概念だけど
実際そういうものでも何でもないんです
時間っていうのは ですから
この現象についてそういうふうにお話ししただけであって
そこでまた違う方向を取ってしまっちゃうんですね
もう修行していたならば
三世論は作らないはずなんですね
そこで全てのものは実体がないんだから空ですよということも
お釈迦様はちゃんとおっしゃってるんです
実体がない すなわち空です
すなわち無我です すごい一般的に空ですよ
無我ですよ 蜃気楼みたいなもんですよと
泡のようなものですよと
ザーッと言葉いっぱい言ってるんです
その中でシュンヤット
空という言葉だけ取り出して
これ数学的な言葉だからシュンヤってのはゼロだから
それで全てはゼロにまとめようとするんですね
一切の存在をゼロという概念に入れてみようではないかと
それが哲学なんですね
そんな余計なことを まあ哲学的な
この頭だけ考える人にとっては
これ未だにヨーロッパ人やら中国系のこのどちらの人々にも
一切はゼロにまとめるという思想っていうのはなかなか大変なことなんですけど
どこにもゼロはなかったんだからね
シュンヤってのはゼロって意味なんです
それで 今の我々が数学を勉強するときは
ゼロには注意になったことを教わってるんですし
だからゼロというヨーロッパの言葉もね
同じ言葉ですしね で それでまあ大変この全てはゼロにまとめようと
また頑張る それでそのサッキャパーリミラという経典はインチキ嘘なんですけど
もう千ジュハンニャーハ
もう八万ジュハンニャーハラミとかいろいろ経典ありますけど
全部はインチキですけど
で 私は簡単に言うのはね
そんな簡単じゃないので
かなり研究して言わなくちゃいけないものなんですけど
もし誰かがこのそんなことを認めないというならば
一緒に経典読んでみましょう
大乗経典読みます 私も
で 読んで私はこの思考はどこで間違ってるか
どこで空転やってるかと
いくら何でも言えるんです
で とにかくそういう経典を見て
龍樹は説得を作りました
彼は嘘は言ってないんです
彼がこれ 私がこう言いますと論ですからね
だから空論になった龍樹の時なんです
それで全て空にまとめたところでもう何もなくなっちゃうんだから
で そこであの また現象を説明しなくちゃいけないんですね
で 現象はゼロから生まれるんだと
で ゼロから全て生まれるんだから
全ての行くところもまたゼロなんですね
そこまで切りがないんです
ゼロがあるとゼロからまた現象が生まれる
現象があると現象が全部ゼロに戻る
そこでゼロは何ですかというと
法身なんですね 法身如来なんです
それで人格化する 人格化したっても
これ誰にもわかりませんだからね
経験できませんだからね
ですから それは誰にもわかりませんというんです
で 誰にもわからないこの法身如来がまた報身如来になっちゃうんです
報身って言ってたかな
報身 報身如来 じゃあ報身如来と誰が見たことがあるかと
いいえ 菩薩だけが見ているんだ
そこで人間知ってる如来は負け犬なんだ
そういうことで ゼロからなぜ菩薩が現れるかというと
それは人々に道を教えるためやと
ですから 誘った人も全部今まで修行しているお坊さんたちやらそういった人々が誰よりもこの在家の菩薩たちが尊くなってしまっちゃうんですね
それ大乗経典では説法しているのは在家なんです
聞いてるのは出家なんですね
逆転するんですね 智慧の第一人者に
もう智慧のゼロ者が説法するんです
[笑い]そこまでおかしくなってしまってもですね
ですから そういうのはもう修行からもうものすごく遠くかけ離れたんだからなんです
そこで例えばもう日本ですごい大事に考えてる般若心経
日本的な般若心経 哲学であるならば
なんでギャーテーギャーテーハー
ハーラーソーギャーテー出てくるんですかね
すごい高度な哲学だと思うんだけど
何の高度な哲学でもないんだよ
ただ言葉で遊んだだけ
遊ぶためにどんな根拠をあてたかというと
色は空であるとお釈迦様も昔おっしゃっていたんですね
色は空であるならば 当然受想行も空なんですね
当然他のものも空になってしまっちゃうんですね
眼耳鼻舌身も色受想行の識も
名色法も全部空になっちゃうんですね
それはまあ 原始経典には別に逆らってるわけじゃないんです
色というものには実体はない
無常である だから無我でもある
故に空であると それをもって色すなわち空であると言って
それで言葉で遊ぶんですね
その故に空は色である
そこでこの子供もしない間違いを犯してるんです
色即是空と それはもう正しいんです
空即是色っていうのは子供さえしない誤りなんです
言葉で遊べばいいと ものすごくもう気持ちよしやったぞと
わかったという感じで書く
自分言ってることは無茶苦茶だから偉大なる呪文やと
私は日本語で覚えてないんだけど
サーグア・ドゥッカ・プラサマナ・マハアマントラ
タッダヤターギャーテーギャーテーパーラギャーテーパーラスンガーテーボーディスワーハ
そういう風にこのゼロにして
ゼロっていうのは掴めないんだから
呪文唱えて拝めばいいんじゃないかということで
悟りもないんだから 修行もする必要はないんだからということになってしまうんです
そこで私が説明したのは
この空即是色というのが間違ってるということは
例えばリンゴは木でありますね
故に木はリンゴです ということなんです
ですから あれは完全に間違いで
それなのにみんな信仰してるんだから
空即是色っていうことはものすごい率先する
すべてのものは真理からもう回転して現れるんだと
大日如来から出てくるんだと
天台師匠とかね この真言系とかね
すごく威張ってそれを解釈するんですね
初めからこのガキでもやれない間違いを
それを直せばいいのに
リンゴは木ですということがものすごいぴったし正しいんです
リンゴは川じゃないんだから
故に木はリンゴですというのはどういうことですか？だから色は空ですよというのはもうぴったり正しいんです
故に空という絶対的な真理は色ですよというと
あり得ない話なんです
その論理はずっと持っていく
で 唯識はそこはあんまり使ってないんだけど
彼はものすごい論理的学者だけど
彼にとっても彼の論理はものすごい
もうそんなにもう力強いものでもないんです
まあ文句言うならばいくらでも言えますけども
学者一人も言ってないんだから
私はもう言う必要はないんです
いろいろたまたま遊びで言う意見なんかは
昔は人が取ってまた論文書いちゃいますからね
まああの それでこのお釈迦様が言ったのは
修行する人が修行して
みんなあの黄狼敵ブータという例えがあるんです
このミルクに牛乳に水を入れても
瞬時に一緒になってしまっちゃうんです
頑張ってかき混ぜなくても
すぐそれでもう一緒になっちゃうんですね
そのように修行する人々は
みんなそういう水と牛乳のように何の逆らいもなしに一緒になるような感じで
みんな一緒になるんだと
問題はないんだと 宗派が現れません
喧嘩にはなりませんと
仏説は というのは 仏説は修行であるということが前提としてあります
修行でないっていうことになったところで
今今の我々見ている仏教になっているんですね
で そこまでは余計な話なんですけど
関係ない 誰にも関係ない話ですが
一応このこの七 三十七のこの法っていうのは
まあ論理的にダブったりしているんだから
ああだこうだとかね いろんなことを言うんじゃなくて
それは実践の目から見ると
そういうふうないろんなカテゴリーにして理解した方が実践する者にはわかりやすい
修行してもない人にとっては四念住というとして
念から始めなくちゃいけない
修行する人にとっては力ない場合は念は力としてさらに実践しなくちゃいけないというふうなことになる
そこで悟るためにそれはなくな
それはなくてはいけない部品としての七つ経の話なんです
ヴィパッサナーはサティですね
ヴィパッサナーはダンマでして
この日本訳ではこの念・名・覚・支と日本訳しているんですね
名がどのようになったかというと
サティ パーリ語でサンボッジャンガと言うんですね
サティサンボッジャンガ
前はボッジャンガだけ書いたんだけど
この項目を言う場合はサンボッジャンガと言うんですね
それは経典でそう出ているんですね
サンボッジャンガというのはこのサンボーディ
サンボーディということですね
いわゆる完全な悟りという意味なんですね
話中でもサンニャスなんとかサンブダなんとか出てきてますからね
サンボーディという言葉にアンガということを入れているだけですね
サンボーディのサンというのは
この八正道で出てくるサンマなんですね
サンマーディッティ 正見
正念 正思惟とか出てきますね
その場合はサンマというふうに出てくるし
で これサンマ切ってしまってサンだけ入れてサンボーディという
ですから まあまろやかというか
的な悟りという意味なんです
妙っていう感じがちょっと合わないかもしれません
念妙覚支と言っちゃう
妙なものじゃないんです
だって妙というのはものすごいきめ細かいという意味もありますけど
そんなにこの発見しがたい
きめ細かいという この顕微鏡で見なくちゃ見えないという意味でもないんです
完全の正しい悟り 完全たる悟りの部品という
ですから 我々はね 念処覚支と書いた方がいいかもしれません
処っていうのは正しいという意味もありまして
もう完全という意味もありますね
正しいという漢字の中に
欠けてないという意味で
ですから 妙覚支よりは処覚支でいいかもしれません
念処覚支 それでこの七覚支の場合は
これは一番気をつけなくちゃいけない
それ七つ揃わないとはもう悟りというこの出来事は起こりません
心の中に で 悟りという出来事は
こういう法とはほとんどまだ関係ないものなんです
でもそこまで ロケットみたいなもんなんです
全部 ロケットはゆっくり立ち上がって
どんどんどんどんスピード出す
それからまた 1番目のロケットは燃えて落ちて
また 2番目 また燃え始めてとかね
いろいろあって また十分スピード出たところで
宇宙船だけは宇宙に飛び出しちゃうんですね
そんな感じで ものなんですけどね
やっぱり心をそういうエネルギーはちゃんと高めていきて
全部揃ってないと悟りという出来事は起こりません
で サティはまあわかってますから
気づくことをネンですね
で ネンは例えばこの膨らみ縮みとかなんとかとか瞑想しても
それはボッジャンガですかと
私はそれできるんだからとかね
左足右足出て歩けるんだと
じゃあ一つ揃ったと そうとかね
そう揃ったわけにはならないんです
で なぜかというと 頭の悪い人にとっては必ずそういうことをやらせるんですからね
左 右 左 はい 右 はい 左とかね
それで悟りの一部というわけにはならないんですね
で まあそれは一応初めであって
で そうやっていると やっぱり
常に自分にサティっていうものはね
自分と一緒になって 常に実践できるようになってくる
わざと努力しなくてもサティすること
あるいは気づくことをできるようになってくると
もっと厳密に物事の変化が見えてくるんですね
左足上げます 左足っていうのは結局アビダンマの立場から見るとあるわけないでしょうに
足立というそちらへの地水火風やら
そういう識の塊りだけであって
で またそれで感覚あるだけであって
ですから 瞑想を進めていくと
進んでいくと もっと明確に
あの物事を気づくこと
物事に気づくことができるようになってくるんですね
いわゆるあるとこ あるところで
この我々見ている現象ではなくて
その現象をなぜ生まれるかというところの世界を見えてくるんですね
例えば花を見てバラだよというのは頭の中で作る現象で
実際に目に触れたのは何ですかと
目にはバラの花入ったわけじゃないんですね
理屈で考えたって それ頭の中に映った
映った映像じゃなくて
作った映像がバラの花である
そこで実際に目に触れたものにサティできると
実際に目に触れるものにはサティができるというところで
本当は音は存在しない
バラの花も存在しない
人も建物もそこには存在しないんです
その時は七覚支のサティになります
そこまでサティを実践しなくちゃいけないんです
で これサティがそこまで成長するために
それにつなげて必要なものは 2番目ダンマヴィッチャヤなんですね